it is your day the album is out
performing at Jingle Ball how are you
feeling oh my god I feel amazing I feel
so thankful I really do I'm excited the
fans are going insane for this album I
mean the reaction on Twitter has been
incredible yeah how does it feel to see
all the love
it feels amazing I mean I just also have
just the sweetest most amazing fans in
the world and just you know seeing their
reaction and seeing how invested they
are in the music and you know seeing
what songs they connect to and them just
kind of pointing things out and that
album feel so exciting and just
rewarding you know I think like writing
the album is amazing but you know like
the second best thing is release day and
getting to see what everybody's saying
you know you're performing tonight I
cannot wait to see your set I'm assuming
you're gonna do seniorita
yeah how is it to put to perform that
without Sean I want it back yeah
but it's fun the fans sing it and it's
cool yeah 2020 is gonna be a big year
for you because we also have Cinderella
to look forward to how involved are you
gonna be in the music for that yeah
super involved I'm writing songs for it
it's like a really collaborative effort
to putting the movies together so is
that kind of insane to know that you
just put out an album then we're gonna
get more kamila music cuz I'm excited
about that I'm so excited and Kay cannon
is the director she's absolutely
incredible and and so talented and just
I think the whole team is like it's such
a joy so I'm excited excited for the
opportunity it's really amazing after
living proof do you know what the next
single is gonna be man I'm gonna tell
you but you'll know so soon is it my
favorite one which ones you know I love
surprised by that actually you'll know
next week okay week you're announcing it
yeah video - no but it'll happen the
video happened okay casual lighting
you're busy one could we see you at
lover fest Taylor's festival that she's
doing you performed with her oh my god I
forgot about that rule honestly be
totally honest I just haven't been on
social media so I saw her incredible
Vogue pictures she looks hot as yeah but
wow I would love to do that we just love
seeing you guys share the stage together
and I love your friendship and she was
supporting your album release how did
that feel so sweet of her I was
literally I was like the sweetest thing
ever it meant so much for me for her to
do that that's so much fun tonight
[Music]